ce qui a déterminé le confinement ce
sont des prévisions tout à fait à focale
et souvenez-vous les modèles
mathématiques de l'impérial college
britannique qui nous aime ton c'est un
peu comme une forme moderne de la
divination que si la france ne contenait
pas ou si le royaume uni ne conflit
n'est pas chacun de ces pays auraient au
moins trois cent mille morts or les
mêmes prédictions prédisait 70 mille
morts à la suède si elle ne contenait
pas la suède n'a pas continué elle n'est
même pas à 10000 morts aujourd'hui
alors bien sûr c'est beaucoup compte
tenu de la faible population de la suède
mais on est très très loin des
prédictions apocalyptiques l'une perial
collègues dont on découvre aujourd'hui
tel sombre complètement fantaisiste
puisque les états unis un pays qui a lui
aussi pour d'autres raisons mal géré la
pandémie qui a peut continuer et bien ce
pays quatre fois plus peuplé que la
france n'est pas n'est même pas à 300000
morts
donc on voit que les trois cent mille
morts qui était annoncé à la france au
royaume uni et qui ont poussé les
gouvernements français et ou
britanniques à faire un nom très dur on
voit aujourd'hui que ces prévisions
apocalyptiques complètement fantaisistes
pour moi je pense que ce qui nous a
poussé à continuer c'est à la fois des
modélisations mathématiques mais qui se
sont complètement fantaisistes
le culte du principe de précaution on le
voit bien aujourd'hui de d'abord edouard
minute quand il était à matignon puis
maintenant jean castex
on a l'impression qu'ils gèrent plus le
risque juridique le risque pénal dans
une société hyper judiciariser donc là
vraiment la dictature du principe de
l'émotion est également la dictature de
l'émotion
relayé par les médias je pense que c'est
tout cela qu'il nous a poussés à
confiner bien pu lui c'est un bilan
rationnelle coûts avantages que nous
n'avons jamais pris le temps de faire
mais il aurait fallu
[Musique]